the woman who moved into this former
home of suspect christian
b wants police to search it she said
she's terrified
he may have hidden evidence of his
crimes here
manfred richter said he saw his neighbor
it was three years ago that christian
bee a convicted pedophile
became the prime suspect for madeleine
mccann's abduction
a year before 2016 he was still living
here in this garden house estate
but suddenly gave up the tenancy and
vanished
the woman who moved in here as a 30 year
old tour guide
she said that soon after she arrived
police asked her about christian bee
but she didn't know him last month when
he was identified as the main
suspect she told friends and neighbors
she was terrified
of what he might have left behind here
forty miles from here police spent three
days excavating
a site where the suspect lived nine
years earlier
they filled up the holes and left they
refused to say if they found what they
were looking for
or if they would search elsewhere
marty brunt sky news braunschweig